From Jurassic Park and Jumanji to Kong: Skull
Island and Journey to the Center of the Earth,
it’s safe to say that humans have long
imagined what it might be like to visit
the prehistoric eras of this planet’s history.
Perhaps it comes from knowing that the Earth
was once so dramatically different back before we
evolved into the dominant species on the planet.
Then again, maybe the fantasy of traveling
back to a land that time forgot is simply
in the appeal of how cool it would be
to see an actual dinosaur up close.
Regardless of the reasoning,
without access to a time machine,
you would find it difficult to make your way
back to any era of the primeval world. Unless, of
course, you happened to accidentally stumble upon
SCP-1265, also known as the Mesozoic Preserve.
This anomalous location is an irregular landmass
found within the basin of the Congo River,
in Central Africa. The oddly shaped portion
of land, measuring fifty kilometers cubed,
is mostly contained within the Democratic
Republic of the Congo. However, around
fifteen of those cubed kilometers spill over into
what is known as just the Republic of the Congo,
the neighboring smaller country of the two that
the Congo is split into. SCP-1265 appears, at
first, to be a very unremarkable area, populated
only by a sparse number of tribal villages.
The place is mostly uninhabited, and, in fact,
there is very little unusual about the local
flora and fauna that marks it as being any
different from the surrounding Congo basin.
That is, unless you count
the dinosaurs, of course.
SCP-1265 is, as its alternate name might suggest,
home to a number of remarkable species that are
thought to have been extinct for many hundreds
of millions of years. While they cannot be seen
all roaming around the area like the famous
moment from the first Jurassic Park movie,
once every thirty days, these creatures will
appear in a group of approximately five.
Collectively designated as SCP-1265-A, these
dinosaurs are not necessarily those known to
have their fossils found within Africa itself, but
appear to be mostly heralding from the Mesozoic
Era, and only those that evolved in similar
climates to those found in the Congo Basin.
Now, while you might expect some of the big names
to come rampaging through the jungle, we’re afraid
we might have to burst your bubble. You will not
find the likes of the famous Tyrannosaurus Rex
or the Brachiosaurus in SCP-1265. As a matter
of fact, it’s actually highly rare to find any
species there that have been previously uncovered
in North America according to the fossil records.
The most relatively common American
dinosaur species to appear as
instances of SCP-1265-A are the Spinosaurus
and Kentrosaurus. So you’re in luck if your
favorite Jurassic Park movie was Jurassic Park 3.
SCP-1265-A dinos aren’t all from the same period
of the Mesozoic either, but the most common
prehistoric eras represented in the Preserve
are the Cretaceous and Jurassic. There have even
been a few Triassic era dinosaurs spotted there,
as well as several non-dinosaur reptiles.
Pterosaurs and similar creatures are known to
exist within SCP-1265 but are not commonly seen.
There are, perhaps highly surprisingly,
a number of dinosaurs that appear as
instances of SCP-1265-A that do not match
any known to be discovered on the fossil
record. These new creatures are known under
the collective designation of SCP-1265-a
instead of the upper case ‘A’.
The SCP-1265-a creatures are known to
be unusually aggressive, especially when
compared to their other counterparts that
have been encountered within the Preserve.
Most of the time, even carnivorous species that
appear in SCP-1265 are normally pretty docile
and show no notable fear or aggression
towards humans unless they are provoked.
SCP-1265-a, however, tends to be the biggest
exception to that rule. These unknown, unrecorded
dinosaurs will often charge directly at any
Foundation researchers on-site when they arrive,
and will even indiscriminately attack
and viscously slaughter other animals
around the Preserve. For a time, the SCP
Foundation was unable to determine the exact
origins of these previously uncategorized
dinosaur species that make up SCP-1265-a,
that is, until some were found within the
fossil record. These creatures that became
identified and recorded through the discovery of
similar or matching fossils soon ceased behaving
with active hostility towards humans in SCP-1265.
Any and all instances of SCP-1265-A are incapable
of leaving the surrounding area that forms
the Mesozoic Preserve. Every time that one
of the dinosaurs attempts to cross the border that
surrounds SCP-1265, the creature will vanish from
sight, completely dematerializing in the blink
of an eye. The SCP-1265-A instance will reappear
shortly after, within three kilometers from
the border. On discovery, the dinosaurs
appear heavily sedated, but still alive.
The existence of SCP-1265 dates back so far
that it even crops up in local folklore.
According to historical records and various
reports of numerous dinosaur sightings over the
years, the Mesozoic Preserve is believed to have
existed for almost two hundred years. The SCP
Foundation conducted interviews with members
of local tribes, most notably a resident
belonging to a nearby M’boshi village,
who shed more light on the role some of the
dinosaurs have had on their tribe’s livelihood.
One tribesperson noted that, while many of the
creatures didn’t eat people, there were occasional
exceptions. One instance of SCP-1265-A that did
appear carnivorous was known as ‘Nguma-monene’,
and was described as resembling a large snake that
walked on all fours like a dog, with a big ridge
over its back. This is most likely referring to
either a specific Spinosaurus or the species as
a whole. Then, there was the dinosaur that
the local people called ‘Mokele-mbembe’,
the largest of all the SCP-1265-A
instances. This was apparently an aquatic,
or semi-aquatic dinosaur, capable of
breathing underwater and large enough
to cause tremors in the ground whenever it walked.
Mokele was most likely a word for the Camarasaurus
species. There was also Mbielu-Mbielu-Mbielu,
sometimes called ‘the beast with planks in
its back’ by the locals, referring
to the Kentrosaurus in SCP-1265.
According to further testimony from the local
tribespeople, the Mbielu and Mokele both possessed
features not present in most modern
illustrations that depict such dinosaurs;
namely, almost all of them possessed feathers.
“They are almost like birds in that way,” the
tribesperson explained, “But they do not
fly. The ones that do fly have no feathers.”
While that might not sound as though
it’s in keeping with the scaly,
reptilian nature of most depictions of
dinosaurs, there’s actually some sense to this.
You see, dinosaurs are mostly theropods, a
subcategory of creatures that evolved into certain
animals still alive today: but we call them birds
nowadays. In the 1990s, at the Yixian Formation in
Liaoning, China, paleontologists uncovered the
first fossil evidence of feathered dinosaurs,
with the bones of a Sinosauropteryx
being the earliest fossils to bear
imprinting that suggested dinosaurs had feathers.
The same local tribesperson also believed the area
of the Congo basin containing SCP-1265 was
hexed, given how none of the dinosaurs could
leave without vanishing spontaneously. The same
happened whenever one tried to take their meat or
their eggs from the Preserve. Apparently, a number
of years before, a gang of hunters had managed to
kill a Camarasaurus and attempted to take the
creature’s carcass from the area. The hunters
were forced to enlist the help of local villagers,
and it took the combined strength of all of them
to move it to the very edge of the Preserve.
Of course, you can guess what happened next:
the creature disappeared, leaving the hunters
unable to claim their prize. Over the years,
the locals have witnessed countless others
try to visit SCP-1265, but not to hunt,
just to catch a glimpse of a wandering dinosaur,
despite how dangerous that endeavor is.
The Foundation conducts monthly expeditions
through SCP-1265, studying any changes to
the wildlife and often harvesting any dinosaur
eggs they come across. After incubating them for
a time, the Foundation’s researchers will study
the newborn dinosaurs until they reach maturity,
at which point they are then released back
into the wild within the Mesozoic Preserve.
Naturally, this all occurs on location
at Site 1265, which is maintained as a
wildlife preserve under the false organization
name the ‘Safe and Clean Planet Initiative’.
During one of these monthly expeditions, one
Doctor Neill, a Foundation researcher, made a
series of notes regarding the prehistoric wildlife
contained within the Preserve. According to Neill,
there are a number of trilobites that dwell
in the water. These are ancient arthropods,
armored precursors to modern insects
and shellfish; basically, picture a big
underwater woodlouse. Apparently, the locals
would fish for trilobites within SCP-1265,
and they taste like prawns when cooked and eaten.
While exploring SCP-1265, Doctor Neill discovered
a family of Baryonyx, a large dinosaur with
a long jaw similar to that of a crocodile,
that mostly fed on fish. Neill observed as
these Baryonyx approached a clan of Spinosaurus,
that according to him, looked more like ducks than
anything else thanks to their coating of feathers.
The researcher mourned a profound disappointment
that he and another doctor, Doctor Moore,
had felt in seeing the Spinosaurus up close.
“Their skeletal structure is completely unsuited
for walking upright, and the less said about
the so-called spine, the better. Scientifically
fascinating, but as a life-long dinosaur
enthusiast, I must grieve for such a titan.”
Later in the expedition, Doctor Neill discovered
the first of a completely new species of dinosaur,
a new SCP-1265-a instance. The creature was
iridescent black, similar in color to a raven,
and possessed four wings, one on each arm
and one on each leg. There was speculation
among the expedition team that this was a brand
new, never before seen species of Microraptor,
possibly native to the continent of Asia during a
prehistoric time period. Being an SCP-1265-a, the
creature was noticeably aggressive, but the team
was able to capture and sedate it, temporarily
naming it the ‘Microraptor foundationii’.
Next, Neill and the rest of the team witnessed
a Postosuchus, a species of crocodile from the
late Triassic era, drinking at the edge of a lake.
The prehistoric croc was suddenly attacked by a
pack of Coelophysis, which were small carnivores
that used their size and speed to take down
large prey as a group. They ate the Postosuchus,
stripping it right down to the bone like a school
of piranha ripping apart a cow in the Amazon.
The intrepid expedition party then witnessed a
fight between a Therizinosaurus and a Carnotaurus,
wherein the victorious Therizinosaurus
dipped its claws in the blood of its fallen
enemy and used it to mark its territory,
scoring trees with Carnotaurus blood.
Finally, the group discovered yet another new
SCP-1265-a instance, this time a ceratopsidae.
These were a sub-group of dinosaurs
that were mainly four-legged herbivores,
including the likes of the famous Triceratops.
This new ceratopsidae, much like many others in
the fossil record, possessed four short, stumpy
legs but only one singular horn for defense. When
the Foundation expedition encountered it, it had
been engaged in combat with a Pachyrhinosaurus;
a horned ceratopsidae highly similar to the
Triceratops, but usually with a row of horns,
or horns protruding from its frill, as
opposed to the Triceratops’ trio of horns.
Unlike other members of the ceratopsidae family,
this new SCP-1265-a instance did not have the
characteristic frill, instead appeared to have
a pair of floppy ears at the top of its head.
The newly discovered dinosaur was also, like the
other SCP-1265-a instances, a lot more aggressive,
and gored the Pachyrhinosaurus with its horn.
At this current moment in time, it is unknown
exactly how the dinosaurs in the Congo basin
actually came to be in SCP-1265. The fact that
they cannot leave its borders suggests that
they were placed there with the intention of
being confined to that area, but there is no way
of knowing if these dinosaurs were lifted out of
their rightful place in time to the modern-day.
It could be that they survived for millions of
years without evolving, or have perhaps traveled
to our time from their prehistoric eras through
some form of temporal gateway, a door through
time. Unless, of course, somebody spared no
expense and grew these dinosaurs from scratch,
but who’d be mad enough to try that, right?
Now go check out “You Can't Resist SCP-666
- Spirit Lodge” and “You'll NEVER Make It To
SCP-084 - Static Tower” for more locations
it’s dangerous to even set foot in!